what can someone do to shore up their
immune system while this is all going on
well a couple things first of all just
being as healthy as you can be you know
wait wait you know I'm I'm getting up
there right now or you know becomes more
of a challenge to stay you know in good
shape you know the more you can do to do
that something you know all about you
know is keeping in shape is really
important a second thing is if you're on
medications like for blood pressure
don't don't miss them take those drugs
because they're really important even
though they may not appear simple you
know you don't have any symptoms a high
blood pressure or something like that
and then I think just you know getting
sleep and eating a healthy diet and
that's about what we can do today to
help get you prepared for this what else
can people do in terms of all this hand
sanitizer jazz and masks is that all
yeah
the hand sanitizers actually are a great
thing for stopping a lot of infectious
diseases they actually are really good
they're good for your hands you know in
terms of the skin they kill the bad bugs
but the whole issue of using your hands
touching your face of people all
concentrate on yes the data is actually
very weak that this what kind of virus
is gonna be transmitted that way so I
wouldn't tell you to stop using hand
sanitizers but don't think it's gonna
have a big impact on this buck do you
see that viral video that's going around
that woman who was giving the address at
the behest of the White House and she
see that she tells people not to touch
their face and then immediately licks
her finger and I did age yeah I saw that
I saw that well why is she telling
people not to touch their face because
you know well the the thought was is
that there are receptors around your eye
right here that actually for this virus
could get in and then get into your body
and you know the data we have on this is
so sparse to say that that's the case
I think the primary thing about
hand-washing is legitimate but one of
the things we want people want to do
something they want to be able to think
they're doing something and so we tell
them wash your hands often in to present
this to prevent this disease and I feel
like we're not being really honest with
the people that the data and and we've
looked at this very carefully really is
about just breathing air and that's a
hard thing to stop
so keep doing the hand-washing but don't
think that that's gonna stop this
disease which you asked about the man to
stop other stuff yes yeah asks there's
two kinds right basically the surgical
mask which just fits over and the reason
it's called a surgical mask is because
it's loose-fitting just fits you know
kind of ties behind you because weren't
worn by surgeons so that they don't
cough or drip into your wound right and
it was never made to protect you from
bugs coming in so those little spaces on
the sides that's not a problem if I'm
breathing into the cloth right in front
of my nose but in terms of the air
coming in on the side they're not
they're not effective at all so people
wear them they look like they're doing
something or not now if you are sick
they may help a little bit from you
transmitting because if you cough then
you cough right into that cloth and
it'll some little in bed in there or not
get out around the other one though is
called an in 95 respirator but for all
intents person looks like a mask it's
just tight face fitting it has the seal
you know at the nose etc it's an
apocalypse mask it could be I don't know
what those are but that's good yes I'm
just saying that that's how I look at it
okay okay
well they're actually we use them all
the time in health care all the time and
they use them in action about 90% of
them are use in industry so there are
grinding things or asbestos etc you know
they don't breathe in all these parts so
if we have one of those that'll do some
they're very effective they're very
effective the problem is we have a big
shortage you know right now we have
hospitals that are down to just a couple
days worth of these masks the
respirators and it's because we don't
stockpile anything in this country you
know we don't have hospitals don't have
the money to do that those Preppers
right now are so excited yeah all the
preppers across the guy I knew it I knew
the day would come
yeah well they are they aren't an
teaches and well you know but well this
is really important because how health
care workers go is how the country I
think will see we're going you know
there been over 4,000 health care
workers in China who are infected many
aman their job and a number of them died
and if in this country we have a real
challenge delivering health care because
we're overwhelmed and then we have
health care workers picking up the
infection like we talked about the group
in milan and we don't have the
protection for them i really believe
that's when the
wait a minute what's going on here what
we're talking about is a complete change
in lifestyle for the next three months
six months and maybe even longer we just
have to realize all over the world that
we are now in a pandemic this is
unprecedented we've never had this in
our lifetimes before and we're going to
have to live differently now we will get
through this things will go back to
normal but for the next six months we're
really going to have to accommodate to
preventing and delaying the spread of
this virus and yes that will mean lots
of social distancing that means
meticulous hygiene it means avoiding
crowded places especially indoors it
means things like staggering the way at
times we go to work so there's not lots
of people crowded together on public
transport it means working at home as
much as we can and have generally avoid
going out it means stopping shaking
hands it means stopping hugs and social
kisses we have to have this social
distancing because this virus only
survives inside human cells it's only
going to go from one person's
respiratory system into another's and if
we can break that chain of transmission
in as many cases as we can then we're
going to greatly delay that curve push
push the peak back into summer
preferably back into late summer when we
have less people with influenza and
other chronic winter related diseases in
our hospitals and flatten that curve
down so that less people are going to be
sick at any one period of time that is
now the aim wash your hands wash your
hands a lot I know you already wash your
hands a lot because you're not
disgusting but wash your hands even more
set up cues and routines in your life to
get you to wash your hands wash your
hands every time you enter and leave a
building wash your hands when you go
into a meeting and when you come out of
a meeting get rituals they are based
around hand-washing sanitize your phone
you touch that phone with your dirty
unwashed hands all the time I know you
take it into the bathroom with you
so sanitize your phone and consider not
using it as often in public maybe tick
tock and Instagram could be home things
only don't touch your face don't rub
your eyes don't bite your fingernails
don't wipe your nose in the back of your
hand
I mean don't do that anyway because
gross don't worry face mask face masks
are for sick people and health care
providers if you're sick your face mask
holds in all your coughing and sneezing
and protects the people around you and
if you're a health care provider your
face mask is one tool in a set of tools
called personal protective equipment
that you're trained to use so that you
can you give patient care and not get
sick yourself if you're a regular
healthy person wearing a face mask it's
just making your face sweaty leave the
face masks in stores for the doctors and
the nurses and the sick people if you
think you have symptoms of Cova 19 stay
home call your doctor for advice if
you're diagnosed with kovat 19 remember
it's generally very mild and if you're a
smoker right now it's the best possible
time to quit smoking I mean if you're a
smoker right now is always the best
possible time to quit smoking but if
you're a smoker and you're worried about
kovat 19 I guarantee that quitting is
absolutely the best thing you can do to
protect yourself from the worst impacts
of kovat 19 virtually every day I get
lots and lots of emails and lots of lots
of comments how do i boost my immune
system people are asking how do I
increase my immunity to reduce my
chances of getting the Kovach 19 virus
or of getting it less severely and as I
understand it I don't know of any way to
boost your immune system but I do know
of lots of way to make what lots of ways
to make it worse so the human immune
system is quite an amazing thing it can
recognize something like 9 billion
foreign antigens things that the body
would recognize as foreign bacteria and
viruses quite an amazing system and I
don't have a way to boost it but and
there are plenty ways to make it work
less optimally to reduce the efficiency
of it but of course remember this
covered 19 is a novel virus it hasn't
been seen before so the immune system is
not going to recognize it and it's going
to have to start making its antibodies
it's gonna have to start the
immunological process from scratch so
how do I get my immune system to be as
good as it can be is the real question
so you can't boost immunity but you can
make it worse so how do we make it as
good as we can make it well the first
thing is make sure you get plenty of
sleep lack of sleep will reduce immunity
so good sleep is important the second
point is make sure you are well
nourished now people talk about taking
lots of this nutrient or loss of that
nutrient or eating lots of that to give
protective effects and the evidence for
that really is not strong if it's there
at all so I would say get plenty of good
nutrition so we want lots of plant
products lots of flavonoids in
flavonoids are in the colored components
of plants so lots of fresh nutrients as
much a week as you know lots of fresh
fruit and vegetables enough protein we
don't need to eat masses of protein we
don't need huge amounts of protein but
we need enough protein
now the nutrient that we're often short
of in the Northern Hemisphere's is
vitamin D so I'm currently taking a
vitamin D supplement that's the only
supplement I'm taking at the moment just
vitamin D because that's the only one
I'm likely to be short of so by taking
huge amounts of extra nutrients I'm not
going to boost my immune system but by
being low on any nutrients I can reduce
the efficiency of my immune system and
because there's no sunshine over English
winters I take vitamin D because my skin
won't make it and we know that vitamin D
deficiency is associated with immune
deficiency so nutrition is one thing but
no evidence for these funds actually
lots and lots of garlic or lots and lots
of vitamin C don't be short of these
things I mean God is good for you anyway
and it's got plant flavonoids and
nutrients and is oh is good but taking
huge amounts of it as I understand it
will not boost the immune system because
I don't think
possible to boost the immune system it's
only possible to keep working at its
normal healthy optimum level now
psychological stress can reduce the
immune function so try and try and
reduce your stress that's the ludicrous
thing to say I'm not quite sure how you
do that but but but try and reduce
stress as much as you can
socializing and sharing things it's
probably one of the best ways to do that
do keep 50 of you can exercise is good
regular exercise is good because these
things optimize health and if you
optimize health you're likely to
optimize immunity get plenty of fresh
air good ventilation I think is
important how serious is this is this
something that we need to be terrified
of or is this overblown or how do you
stand on this well first of all you have
to understand the timing of it in the
sense that is just beginning and so in
terms of what hurt pain suffering death
is account happens so far is really just
beginning this is going to unfold for
months to come yet
and that's I think what people don't
quite yet understand what we saw in
China I'm convinced as are many of my
colleagues as soon as they release all
of these social distances is mandated
stay in homes haven't left your home in
weeks and weeks kind of thing when they
go back to work they're on planes trains
subways buses crowded spaces
manufacturing plants even China is going
to come back again and so this really is
acting like an influenza virus something
that transmits very very easily through
the air we now have data to show that
your infectious before you even get sick
and in some cases quite highly
infectious just breathing is all that
you need to do so from this perspective
I can understand why people would say
well wait a minute flu kills a lot more
itself every year than this does and are
we remind people this just was beginning
probably the best guesstimate we have
right now on what limited data we have
is say this is gonna be at least 10 to
15 times worse than the worst seasonal
flu year we see 10 to 15 times worse in
terms of fatalities yeah yeah and just
illness in fact I just brought some
numbers we conserve early estimate that
this could require 48 million
hospitalizations 96 million cases
actually occurring over 480 thousand
deaths
that can occur over the next three to
seven months with this situation so this
is not one that to take lightly we have
an employee at our Center for infectious
research and policy at the University of
Minnesota and she has a dear friend who
lives in Milan Italy and she works at a
hospital there and she texted us to this
employee of ours last night and this was
an email that came out yesterday from
one of their physicians in Milan at the
largest hospital there he said I just
got a very disturbing message from a
cardiologist at one of the Milan's
largest hospitals they're deciding who
they have to let die they aren't
screening the staff anymore because they
need all hands on deck and they have
very small areas of the hospital
dedicated to non kovat patients where
they still screen doctors everybody else
is dedicated to colvett patients so even
if they're positive meaning that they're
sick they don't and but they don't have
a severe cough or fever then they have
to work he says that that they're seen
an alarming number of cases in the
forty-something range rage and as he
took horrible cases so we need to stop
thinking that this isn't only an old
person's disease that this is what's I'm
gonna unfold not just in wuhan it's
unfolding in Milan it's unfolding here
in Seattle and this is what's going to
continue to rolling Lee unfold
throughout the world so we really got to
get information out to the public there
is so much missing from information
right now and you know we're gonna be
this for a while this is not gonna
happen overnight I worry I keep telling
people were handling this like it's a
corona blizzard you know two or three
days momentum normal this is a corona
virus winter and we're gonna have the
next three months or more six months or
more that are going to be like this for
the average person that is sitting
around reading these articles that say
don't worry our readings are there's
articles that say this is the end of
humanity what would what could these
people do like what what could they do
and what do they do if they get infected
well first of all neither those kind of
articles are correct and we have to make
sure that we get that message out to
people that is Sarah we need Straight
Talk right now you know and part of it
is it's so hard to you hear from people
who supposed experts what's this going
to happen or not
but you know and and let me just give
you an example because we've heard a lot
about well it's going to go away with
the the Khurana of the coronavirus with
the seasons okay when it warms up it'll
go away well you know the other
coronavirus is that we have that we've
had to worry about with SARS which
appeared in 2003 in China and when that
came out of China in February 2003 it
took us a little while to figure out
that these people really aren't that
infectious tilde five or six of their
illness and then they really crash and
burn and many of them would die but what
we did was basically by knowing that
identify these cases in their contacts
quickly and so if they had symptoms
brought him in put him in these
isolation rooms so they wouldn't infect
anybody else and it took until June to
bring out under control that had nothing
to do with the seasons MERS which is
another corona virus that's in the
Middle East it's in the Arabian
Peninsula
yeah the natural reservoir for that is
camels in China and by the way SARS it
was palm civets and we a type of animal
food road that we got out of the markets
there in the Arabian Peninsula we're not
gonna euthanize up 1.7 camels you know
to try to get rid of MERS and there it's
a hundred and ten degrees out and this
virus is transmitted fine thank you I
mean it goes from animals to people it
goes in the hospitals there's no
evidence that seasonal there so that's a
good myth to expose right away this is
not something that's gonna cure up when
it gets warm it you know if it does it
won't be because there's a model for it
what will it be because how does a how
does something like SARS run through a
population and then stop being around
anymore well it wouldn't have but had we
had good Public Health had we had you
know the same kind of transmission we're
seeing with this corona virus where your
infectious before you ever get sick
where your highly infectious remember
with SARS now you didn't really get
infectious tell you're a six or you know
six days of illness and you knew that
you were in trouble and then you can
isolate you and we didn't understand
that at first and we transfer virus
transmitted so that's why SAR stopped
murder stops because we don't get rid of
the camels so it keeps hitting humans
day after day but then when they go to
the hospital we'd no longer allow those
individuals to transmit to others in the
hospital because we do what we call good
infection control as soon as they get
there they're in special rooms with
special Mass and all this kind of thing
and so in that regard these coronavirus
can be stopped this one's not as I said
to be the top of the program this is
like trying to stop the wind we
influenza transmission you never hear
anybody saying in a bad flu seasonal flu
year you know we're gonna stop this one
if you don't have vaccine that works you
don't it's just breathing that's all it
is
so what's best-case scenario here well I
think as I laid out to you before you
know this could be ten times worse than
a really bad seasonal flu year and our
grandchildren well it will hit you know
primarily the older population and those
with underlying health problems but as I
mentioned also you know we have a lot of
people who have other risk factors
obesity high blood pressure is another
risk factor where you can have a really
bad outcome with this and so we don't
quite know what it's going to do yet I
think you know we've been right on the
mark predicting where it's going to be
today
I think from here on out I can tell you
it's going to stay around for months
it's not going to go away tomorrow we
got to stop thinking about if we just
get through tomorrow that's it so we're
going to go to schools we're going to
tell people not to go into public or and
it can still big events how long are we
prepared to do that what are we going to
do we have to ask ourselves that I think
the big thing is eventually enough
people get infected or it'll be like
putting reactors and the rods and you
know rods in the reaction I should say
and then that stops it by itself but how
so because if you're if two of the three
of us in this room were immune right now
to it because we'd had it and recovered
and had protection because of natural
protection then I couldn't transmit to
anybody so that's what's going to happen
if you had enough people will get
infected ultimately then it'll slow down
and stop transmission that way but
that's the heck of a price to pay to get
there yeah I'm at home they can get you
cozy smoked metal stogie
let us finish the bike ride and a little
bit of workout and I just you know keep
staying at home away from the crowds and
away from outside the reason why I'm
saying that is because I still see
photographs and videos of people sitting
and outside cafes all over the world and
having a good time and hanging out in
crowds that is not wise because that how
you can get the virus that's how you get
it by contact with other people so stay
away from crowds stay away from being in
restaurants and outdoor cafes especially
now in springtime though all the kids
are going to the beach and celebrate and
drink and ordered stuff this is not a
good idea so stay away from the crowds
go home and then we can overcome this
whole problem this whole virus in no
time but you got to go and follow those
orders just remember stay at home don't
don't go the crowds put their took it
down
so I've come to the thing now to wash my
hands
I want it medium I'm going to turn that
on now now the first thing to do is to
wet your hands all over thoroughly first
like that get your hands wet and today
I'm going to use some now after you've
got your hands you can actually knock
that off with your elbow if you want so
today but you can equally well use a bar
so that's all absolutely fine and
quickly just get on your hands and then
the first movement I want to show you is
that how that's palm to Palm
cleaning the palms of your hands like
that nice clean bombs then the next
thing we want to clean is the backs of
our hands in the front of our hands so
for that we do this and we interlace our
hands like that on that side if you've
got a wedding ring on like me just
loosen it a bit and wash underneath
clinically we would never wear stone
rings but blind wedding bands are fine
and on that side then on the other side
lined up so we're doing on both sides
then we want to do it in lace fingers
again but front to front of my mouth
that movement now the next one is grip
to grip like this don't want to do it
like that get into all those palms and
that was I guess you've knuckles into
your into your bonds side to side then
the other way like that now a lot of
people forget is their thumbs
so one thumb here and a twisting
movement like that the other thumb there
and it's twisting movement my line now I
want to give up palms and fingertips a
particularly good clean so now we go
round our palms with our fingertips
first on that hand and on that hand
don't want to do the wrists which are
the risks and again on that side there
we are so we've done both times now now
we can use our elbow and now we're gonna
finish
really
not less than 20 seconds really 20 to 30
seconds and then we don't want to trip
down to that dirt it's out knock it off
with the elbow now I like to use some
roll like this you get a couple of walls
a piece of lie down I'm just going to
dry my hands trying to know the notches
drying them to my ring
and now my hands are very easily now if
I'm in a public toilet I've now got a
bit of a problem because I need to get
out of the public toilet or if I have a
tap with an old-fashioned twizzle II
think then I could turn that off by
putting that on the top like that so I'm
not reader teeing my hand and then if we
go over to the door here go over to the
toilet I think the door door here is
closed I'm gonna do I'm gonna keep that
like that and I'm gonna put that on the
door handle because public toilets on a
toy too dirty places I'm gonna open the
handle by that side and get out then I'm
going to close that in and and then
discard everything into a bin and then I
can leave with clean hands if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there
it's commercially closed there's not a
lot you can do right now